Corea del Norte cruzó una línea roja con
su vecino del sur Peón yang lanzó al
menos 10 misiles uno de ellos cayó a 57
kilómetros de las aguas territoriales
surcoreanas un suceso insólito según el
ejército de seúl
Corea del Norte han lanzado tres misiles
balísticos uno de ellos cayó al sur de
la línea límite al norte en el mar de
Japón Es la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano llega a una zona tan cercana
a nuestras aguas territoriales en el mar
de Japón esto es muy raro no lo
toleraremos nuestro ejército responderá
con firmeza
sin demora las autoridades pidieron a
los habitantes de la isla surcoreana de
huyehundo resguardarse en búnkeres casi
simultáneamente seúl tomó represalias
disparando tres misiles tierra aire el
presidente Johnson denunció una invasión
territorial por parte de Japón el Primer
Ministro que chida expresó su
preocupación
Corea del Norte acaba de lanzar un misil
balístico estoy dando instrucciones para
informar al público y confirmar su
seguridad
Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur están
realizando actualmente en mayor
ejercicio aéreo conjunto de su historia
se trata de maniobras agresivas para
pyongyang que pronto podría realizar
según Sealy Washington la séptima prueba
nuclear de su historia